the holidays are here in full swing
which gives you two options spend your
evenings with family and loved ones or
hide away from those weird relatives and
catch up on all Netflix newest TV shows
and movies this December
you can definitely expect plenty of
holiday themed movies to hit the service
but that's not all here's a breakdown of
everything you'd be crazy to miss on
Netflix in December 2017 starting with
the Netflix originals dark season 1 when
two kids go missing in a small German
town their families are plunged into a
mystery that goes back decades that's
the premise for dark a German language
Netflix original series the morose
atmosphere and flat color palette
showcased in the trailer evoke immediate
comparisons to stranger things although
we're hoping the 10 episode first season
goes in a new direction and delivers
something wholly original dark premieres
on December 1st easy season to an
all-star cast is slated to appear in the
second season of Netflix anthology
series easy Marc Maron Dave Franco and
Aubrey Plaza are just a few of the names
showing up in the new season and series
creator Joe Swanberg is again taking
over writing and directing duties for
each of the second seasons eight
episodes the entire season premieres on
December 1st my happy family
Sundance Darling my happy family is
getting a Netflix exclusive release on
the 1st of the month the georgian film
starts with three generations of a
tight-knit family living in a single
home only for their lives to be flipped
upside down when 52 year-old menara
makes a shocking announcement she's
moving out tender and emotional my happy
family paints a subtle portrait of what
it means to leave everything you know
and the struggle to cope with the fact
that your happy family is really
anything but voyeur true crime has never
been so intimate the Netflix original
documentary is an adaptation of 2016's
the four years Motel a nonfiction
account centered on Gerald Foos a motel
owner who installed special grates in
his motel rooms and would allow him to
spy on his guests without their
knowledge the book was written by
journalist Gay Talese who also stars in
the documentary the film rights were
actually purchased by Steven Spielberg
in 2016 the plans for his feature film
were shelved following news that Netflix
was producing a documentary on the
subject take a peep
when Moyer drops on December 1st Craig
Ferguson tickle fight longtime Late Late
Show host Craig Ferg
is landing on Netflix with an all-new
comedy stand-up special this will Bart
Ferguson's second special on the
streaming service following his 2013
special Craig Ferguson I'm here to help
if tickle fight takes the same cues as
his prior special it's bound to be
hilarious timely and completely
irreverent when a smart woman wants to
stay married to a guy after the wind and
she fountains them up a little bit not
too much just enough to slow the bird
down in case it gets any idea
look for it on December 5th El Camino
Christmas when five people are taken
hostage in a liquor store on Christmas
Eve the holidays quickly turned into a
nightmare
El Camino Christmas stars Tim Allen Dax
Shepard Jessica Alba and Vincent
D'Onofrio in a comedic crime story about
one man's search for his father that
goes horribly wrong the movies based on
the script by Ted Melfi who wrote and
directed the oscar-nominated hidden
figures as well as st. Vincent check it
out in December 8 the Crown's season to
Netflix award-winning historical drama
the crown is gearing up for season two
continuing the story of a young Queen
Elizabeth the second her marriage to
Prince Philip and her struggles to
maintain order in a constantly changing
world scarred by war the second season
will see the return of the main cast
along with the addition of Dexter's
Michael C Hall in the role of John F
Kennedy the wait is over on December 8th
Judd Apatow the return despite being the
man behind the camera on countless smash
hit comedies including the 40 year old
virgin knocked up and trainwreck you
don't often get a chance to see Judd
Apatow in front of the camera that's all
changing with Judd Apatow the return a
stand-up special that sees Apatow step
on the stage for the first time in over
25 years
look for it on December 12 erased season
1 based on the manga the same name
erased is an all-new live action show
about a man who discovers that he has
the ability to travel back in time to
prevent past tragedies from happening
this will mark the third adaptation of
the manga a previous to being an anime
series that premiered in January 2016
and a live-action film that screen in
Japan in March 2016 get ready for an
all-new telling of the story when erased
season 1 drops on December 15th the
ranch part for the Aston Kutcher led
sitcom the ranch has been an audience
favorite since its 2016 premiere
although critics haven't been
particularly kind
show the story centers on Colt Bennett a
football player who couldn't cut it in
the big time so he's forced to move back
to the family ranch in Colorado as they
did with the latest season of fuller
house Netflix released each season of
the ranch broken up into two parts part
four which is the second part of season
two hits Netflix on December 15th
ultimate beast master season 2 who
doesn't love watching contestants bash
their way through a seemingly impossible
obstacle course and the spirit of ninja
warrior ultimate beast master pits at
lead athletes against the clock as they
struggle to make it past a series of
grueling physical challenges season two
arrives on December 15th so sit back and
live vicariously through the pain of
others the American Way
wormwood the first teaser for Netflix
hotly-anticipated show wormwood dropped
way back in August and the hype has only
grown since then part fiction and part
documentary the show dives into the dark
history of the CIA's infamous MKULTRA
experiments focusing specifically on one
scientist who was involved in the
secretive operation from oscar-winning
director Errol Morris wormwood promises
a paranoia fuelled journey into the dark
heart of government conspiracy settle in
for the six-part mini-series on December
15th hello my 20s season 2 also known as
age of youth in its origin country of
South Korea this comedy-drama series
follows five college-age girls from
different walks of life who live in the
same house if you haven't seen the first
season yet now would be a good time to
go back and watch it because season two
arrives in December 18th
Russell Howard recalibrate British
comedian Russell Howard has been selling
out shows across the UK and now he's
slated to star in a Netflix exclusive
stand-up special Russell Howard
recalibrate cue up the laughs on
December 19th the Indian detective
season 1 starring Russell Peters
Christina Cole and William Shatner the
Indian detective is a Canadian crime
comedy about a Toronto cop who gets
drawn into a murder investigation while
visiting his family in India the first
season consists of four episodes all of
which are slated to arrive on Netflix on
December 19th la casa de papel season 1
this heist thriller made waves with its
Spanish television premiere and now
Netflix is rolling it out to
international audiences on December 20th
the title translates to house
of paper and the story follows eight
bank robbers planning to pull off the
biggest heist Spain has ever seen if you
don't mind the subtitles you can Vinge
the entire first season when la casa de
papel drops later this month peaky
blinders season four ever since its 2013
premiere peaky blinders has steadily
gained more and more attention with
critics praising the show's characters
acting and story among many other
elements that come together to make this
powerful drama as effective as it is
whether you've been waiting eagerly for
season four or just now starting the
entire series mark your calendar for
December 21st and get ready for the
brand-new season bright written by max
landis and directed by David Ayer bright
is a Netflix original film starring Will
Smith as Darrell Ward an LAPD officer
who has to team up with an orc to stop
an evil force threatening to destroy the
world equal parts crime thriller and
fantasy bright promises to take on the
buddy cop trope that'll definitely be
unique if nothing else look for it on
December 22nd fuller house season 3 new
episodes ever since Netflix released the
first part of season 3 of fuller house
in September fans have been eagerly
anticipating the season second half
coach coach the wait will soon be over
the final nine episodes of season three
are slated for a December 22nd release
just in time to tune in with the whole
family over the holidays the toys that
made us season 1 get ready for a blast
from the past with the toys that made us
Netflix new nostalgia driven series that
looks back on the iconic toys of the 80s
and 90s and the stories behind them if
you're thinking he-man GI Joe and
transformers you're on the right track
it's two against two the show premieres
in December 22nd just in time to make
you rethink your holiday wish list cable
girls season two set in 1928 cable girls
tells the story of four women who get
jobs at a state-of-the-art telecom
company in Madrid focusing on their
troubled past lives and the
relationships that emerge as they
finally get a new lease on life
season 1 served up plenty of
hard-hitting drama and chances our fans
can expect more the same from the second
season which will be available for
streaming on Christmas Day Todd berry
spicy honey veteran stand-up comic Todd
berry is joining the Netflix lineup this
December with Todd berry spicy honey a
new comedy special that promises more of
Barry's signature dry style coupled with
brand new material that fans are sure to
love tune in on December 26 for all the
laughs it's the day after Christmas what
else are you gonna do travelers season 2
once you're done burning through future
man and 11/22/63 over on Hulu head back
to Netflix to get your time-travel fix
with the season 2 premiere of travelers
created by Brad Wright the man behind
Stargate sg-1 and Stargate Atlantis
travelers follows four people hundreds
of years in the future who transport
their minds back into new bodies in the
21st century in an attempt to prevent
the dystopia that will become of our
world season 2 of the sci-fi drama will
be released globally on Netflix on
December 26th Bill Nye saves the world
season 2 part 1 the first season of Bill
Nye saves the world was met with a storm
of controversy most people disliked the
content and the political nature of the
show while others were just upset that
night didn't seem to be the same science
guy we loved from the 90s
either way the majority of the show's
audience found something to hate and the
season 2 announcement trailer made the
unusual decision to highlight the
negative reactions to the first season
because that always helps love it or
hate it
Bill Nye saves the world is returning
with the second season landing on
December 29th lamont season 1 originally
aired in France Lamont or the Mantis is
a psychological drama about the search
for a vicious criminal who's recreating
the crimes perpetrated by the Mantis a
psychopath who operated 20 years
previous
the police have no choice but to turn to
the mantas for help tracking down the
new murderer the 6 episode miniseries
premieres on December 29th dave
chappelle equanimity netflix is ending
the year with a new comedy special from
dave chappelle his third to hit netflix
in 2017 netflix describes dave chappelle
equanimity as a return to his roots
after Chappelle's long hiatus from the
spotlight in some mixed reviews on his
previous Netflix specials we can only
hope his newest outing delivers on that
promise check it out when it lands on
New Year's Eve Billy do we mix that does
it for the Netflix originals coming out
in December 2017 now let's look at
everything else that's hitting the
streaming service new movies we know
government plots and space battles don't
usually come to mind when you think of
the holidays but Netflix is ushering in
a few action movies this month that will
give you a break from the snow and sleet
V for Vendetta will be available on
December first followed by guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 on the 5th Netflix is
also doubling down on classic comedy
films relive the past with both original
Ace Ventura films hitch nacho libre and
while you were sleeping on December 1st
and if those get you in the mood for
family movie night you're in luck from
trolls holiday special landing on
December 6th - all three films in the
Santa Clause franchise and December 12
you won't be able to escape the
festivities this year even if you try
of course the holidays aren't all about
love and family sometimes you need a
dose of betrayal and revenge just to
round things out on December 1st Netflix
is adding drama classics like eight-mile
and Full Metal Jacket to their lineup
followed by Nicolas Winding reference
pusher on December 27th and the thriller
genre Netflix is adding 2003's
dreamcatchers starring Tom Jane then on
December 23rd tune in for creep to the
sequel to the 2014 underground hit mark
Duplass returns as everyone's favorite
psycho with Patrick Brice back in the
director's chair
finally the documentary lineup is
definitely cause for excitement with the
addition planet Earth to the 2016 follow
up to BBC's award-winning 2006 nature
series if you're a fan of nature Doc's
get ready to experience the world like
you've never seen it before again on
December 25th other documentaries to
watch this month include the farther
Voyager in space a PBS production about
the Voyager probes check it out in
December first and then look for
discovering Bigfoot and freeway cracking
the system on December 15th new
television you'll find plenty of shows
to binge on outside of the Netflix
originals lineup highlights this
December include the magician's season 2
on December 11 halt and catch fire
season 4 on December 14th and Reggie
Yates outside man on the 15th if you're
into cooking shows Netflix has you
covered there as well
with Chef in my fridge dropping on
December 1st and season one of Ainslie
eats the streets on December 14th no
matter what you're looking for there's
bound to be a show for you thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]